madame la présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de la
santé je voudrais revenir sur la
question de la vaccination dans le cadre
de la variole du singe plusieurs
réponses qui ont été apportées
aujourd'hui mais je pense qu'il faut que
nous en précision la portée tout d'abord
et la haute autorité de santé a fait des
recommandations très rapidement
d'ailleurs delvingt mais cela a été
souligné toutefois nous avons beaucoup
de remontées de nos concitoyens qui
souhaitent se faire vacciner qui
aujourd'hui n'y arrive pas j'ai moi même
tenté ce matin d'obtenir un rendez-vous
pour tester la sphère est effectivement
le rendez vous n'est pas donné avant
trois semaines voire un mois ce qui est
incompatible avec les recommandations de
la haute autorité en qu'un de particules
en cas nécessitent et de prophylaxie
post-exposition
deuxième point concerne les stocks la
question des stocks de vaccins est
évidemment fondamental y aurait un
million de stocks aux états unis les
allemands ont tachetée de 140 mille
doses vous nous avez dit tout à l'heure
que le déstockage aurait lieu autant que
nécessaire mais ça ne répond pas à la
question du stock quel est le stock
aujourd'hui parce que cette question en
fait est aussi celle au-delà de la
variole du singe de la question de la
préparation du pays à une éventuelle
remontée de la variole sous la forme
d'une attaque terroriste en 2006 il y
avait un plan de préparation nationale
en cas de l'utilisation de la variole à
des fins terroristes et à l'époque en
2006 le plan national disposait que nous
avions 75 millions de doses alors je
vous pose la question à la ministre quel
est l'état de notre stock